you joked about four through ten but how
far do you plan in advance do you get
ideas and think oh that will go for the
next movie and I'm bearing in mind that
this talk of an Expendables at some
point okay
are there any women that you would like
to see in that yes there are and we're
now starting to see that you don't have
again totally depend on actresses per se
pura you're going to need a certain kind
of physicality to pull that off getting
back to how many Expendables avi what's
the deal how many do you want about
twenty seven okay Jason how many do you
have patience for pacing for what's long
well how many Expendables before it says
alright I'm done I want to be an
Expendables well the idea is to make at
least another two or three and then
we'll see how in other words I'm joking
here but we'd like to just continue this
because it's it's an ongoing experiment
to you have a great franchise and the
Avengers in all that situation where you
can branch off and do other things
ideally I would love to see some of
these characters like Antonio or the
young expand let's go through their own
movies I know that's maybe a pipe dream
and then you come together for the big
festival of violence or the great
challenge of whoever the villain is but
that would be that would be the ideal so
I think I think it all depends on this
one here but I could definitely see one
and a half at least four okay maybe two
more and then you never know but the
third one I've always found is when I
started doing something we've been
franchise I was ridiculed for it we were
all worse like a little friendly but I
was always intrigued with television how
can they do ten years of the same
character you know all in the family
same location and yet you watch it but
you do one film ago l dr. B that's the
end some films are designed like that
but other films have characters that
continue to grow and manifest different
personality changes now with the
Expendables you got a situation here
where we're in uncharted waters
to put all women together in our will
that really work or do you have to put
in perhaps perhaps some women that are
actually really known to be tough other
MMA fighters and and then is it are the
Expendables really part of a divorce
with Barney and say Sigourney Weaver was
my wife and she inherited half the
explainable so that's that's like oh I
got to deal with that too I lost the
house and my mercenaries in the group oh
my god so there's it's all these things
you're trying to concoct so when we do
it it doesn't just languish there as it
oh it's just a use of the name it
actually is something would hold its own
so sounds like you'd like to face off
against the Avengers ultimately sly is
that the idea Expendables versus the
Avengers that's where you're going yeah
yeah if we could we'd be the earthbound
Avengers Christopher bide sly and Abby
getting back to the Expendables
I was talking to Jacqueline Bisset this
morning and she'd love to play the
villain if that film ever comes off we
never thought about as a villain but
look about Expendables we are right now
in the families of their script we've
got lots of idea about who is going to
be all the the action movie star like
this woman and we planning to do it
beginning of next year and that's all I
can say about this movie right now
you